Cortés makes it easy to roll out updates
to your applications by modifying
the deployments and managing them.
It's major update time.
Let's modify the off deployment
configuration file to use Version 2.0
of the author container image.
Now will apply or
update using the coup apply command.
We can track the progress of our of
the plumbing using the COO CTO describe
deployments
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Let's walk through
the output of this command.
Here's our only update strategy.
This ensures that the right number
of PAs are always available.
Once the rolling update is complete
we can view the running pads for
the off service.
Here we see the new replica
said that's being used
to ensure that we are running the latest
version of our off container.
Once the rolling update is complete
we can view the running path for
the off service.
Notice how long they have been running.
The new version of the off Pod
have replaced the previous ones.
We can verify that the off Pod
is running the new version of
the off container using
the COO CTO described command.
Updating deployments this way keeps us
with a clean declarative approach for
rolling out update Kubernetes
makes it easy to roll out changes
to our applications using
a declarative approach.
Whether you have 1 or
100 pause in a deployment,
Kubernetes makes it easy to update
them using a few simple commands.